Richard the million-dollar question is
how does one stay focused and on and
determine with their goals when
everything seems to go wrong obviously
focused and determined that everything
seems to go wrong that's true yeah
that's our operations I might be out of
chicken you know reality chicken what I
did was a startup business on leader
choose anything back in California uh I
had months where I'm really worried
about not making payroll every day every
day god I remember it too so well
vividly it was an emotional
rollercoaster ride and some days I used
to say right today was a great day three
steps forward two steps back but some
days it was to stay back there was a lot
of good news and then would land a big
order and then we wouldn't have enough
people in business would go crazy on
hiring and then you notice the skits are
freely as a leader you you can't free
your colleagues out and share this stuff
for them this one day you you throwing
you scale it up you're hiring people and
then if the kind of order pipeline dries
up leaving a while we need to take costs
down and there is that schizophrenia you
need to dementia but how you manage that
number one I think you need strong was
an emotional is it it back to your
passion back to connecting you with
mission because then you know it's
worthwhile and you can't expect anything
special in life to be created from
anything apart from I'm a really good
mission shorts tremendous national and
then fun put all your energy into
execution and hard graft never hurt
anybody honestly and promise you that
and I don't know anything really special
sustainable you create apart from a
really awesome execution and hard work
and unless you win the lottery or
something you know but otherwise you
don't you do if you don't do anything
special and create something unique and
magical and as you really execute it you
guys say to taste truly cool yeah when I
find it difficult and when things go
wrong for me it's actually really sort
of thrive on that I get excited because
it's you know you move forward from pain
so you know if sales are down and you're
having a tough year you know you just go
back to all that I always go back to the
basics so it's like you know are we are
we delivering
products to our customers at the right
price you know are we keeping touch with
in the right way what are our
competitors doing are they doing
something better than us at the moment
that we haven't noticed you know and
then sometimes it can be outside your
control so you can't control the economy
you know and so you have to pay
attention to those things and you win
economies are struggling or you have
difficult times like you don't know
what's going up in the UK i'm looking at
abroad at the moment because you know
there's lots of opportunity for us
abroad with the pound changing and all
that kind of thing so I think I'm you
know makes you more resourceful it's
like you know they were sort of this
morning that you know just entrepreneurs
they kind of if you want to do something
like we like we wanted to do things
today where we wanted to get places and
you know we wouldn't take no for an
answer right stage change there we go
and I think the other thing obviously we
talk about this in previous kind of
Google Hangouts of laps find someone you
trust you've been through your journey
before and you know just go for a coffee
with them and just just be honest with
yourself and asking for advice when your
face I'm really tough times and the good
news is in business everything can be
overcome with great determination
conviction and belief and if you still
believe in your passion and you got an
awesome product there's always where you
can find to grow an actually Jeremy's
point is the answer is never more
resources it's all about resourcefulness
the source fulness and it's an
entrepreneur you've got bundles of
resourcefulness I would say to like to
add to both both of the points are you
got to enjoy the process you know you
have to enjoy the work not just be
attached to the outcome a lot of people
i have a goal i want to hit this things
where I want to be and I'm going to do
all this crap to get to that goal but if
you don't enjoy the work then when you
don't hit that goal that's super
frustrating you're going to quit where
the most successful entrepreneurs yeah
we have goals we have big do you want to
hit this milestone you know I want to
hit execute a million subscribers on
YouTube but it's not the point I'm not
doing stuff just to hit a min
subscribers on youtube I like the crap I
like making these videos I like making
stuff for you and I find when you don't
enjoy the process of your business then
it's really hard to stay motivated so
you know there's going to be a lot of
down days you may not get that yes from
the customer and that's understandable
like you're gonna get down on yourself a
little bit but what gets me back in is I
just drive back into the work like I'm
going to make an
the video because I love it right I get
hugs from my work right it feels my soul
so like so you have to be doing
something that you love and not just do
a bunch of crap to get to that goal
enjoy the process and the process keeps
you through the thing that gets you
through the crap of building the
business is enjoying the craft